Now, in the past lectures, we have talked about file formats.
We basically talked about file formats being nothing else but a data structure
that would actually store the intensities of each and every pixel in an image.
But in some instances, someone might say, that's a lot of missing information,
why don't we get a lot of information that's raw to the sensor and
actually just save that.
And that's behind the whole concept of a Camera RAW file format.
Basically, what you do in a camera RAW file format, is basically,
you store the minimally processed data from each and every part of the sensor.
Each and every point that's measured light, you save the original or
as close to the original raw data from there.
The images in a camera RAW format are encoded in a device-dependent color space.
Sometimes, of course, it's a propriety color space.
But each camera has a specific form of a color space.
And, what it basically does is, image is stored in that and
after you save it the camera manufacturers do provide information on
how to take that color space and make it much more readable on a computer.
More importantly, it also captures the radiometric characteristics of the scene.
Radiometric basically meaning that the light and
the intensities of the colors from the scene are captured in
a raw format rather than manipulated in any way whatsoever.
Many of you who do advanced photography know that in some cameras,
there is a lot of calibration tools that allow you to control the light and
also the colors very specific to the scene, sometimes by
doing white balancing or different types of color contrast and stuff like that.
One of the beautiful things about camera RAW is, since it's capturing the raw
radiometric characteristics of the scene, you can do all of that after the fact.
In essence what it does is basically let's you get the image from
the camera's sensor data.
So the whole concept of a Camera RAW file format is,
it's to kind of replicate the whole photographic negative.
One of the things that went away when we started going from
film to digital images is, while we had the instant gratification of
seeing the image as soon as it was captured, we basically got it processed,
it was not something we could manipulate anymore.
One of the beautiful things about doing dark room
photography was always that once the film was exposed,
when you were sitting in a dark room, you could do a variety of
different ways of exposing that film to give you different contrast levels.
Well, that now is possible through camera RAW format, because once you
have the camera format with things like the radiometric characteristics and
stuff like that, you could actually do a lot more.
So in essence, one of the advantages of a camera RAW file format is
that they're minimally processed, device dependent, and therefore actually,
you know, you know know more about how the perfect response for
that specific camera's devices.
Oh. This, so it's device-dependent, so
basically, the colorspace is really known by the manufacturers, and
therefore they allow you to read out the best values from it.
Radiometrics, all the color values are well defined and captured raw.
And of course, this represents an equivalence class to the form,
photographic negative, let's you control things after the fact.
And it allows you to do things like changes in dynamic range, color, and
most of the information of the captured image is available to you.